hello everyone and welcome to another
game from the European Team Championship
yesterday we've seen Magnus Carlson the
highest rated player in the world uh
draw a game he escaped by the what's the
expression by the uh by the yeah I don't
know what the expression is but I I know
it's something uh o of his teeth uh but
I can't remember how it goes and uh uh
his team lost the match as a result not
as the direct result to his game but if
he for example won on board then it
would be a draw H but now it would be
really great for him as he does have the
wi pieces and his opponent is over 300
rating points low rated at him that he
grabs a full point for his team uh they
are playing against the Iceland and he's
facing on board one uh strong
Grandmaster Karin greton and uh by the
time I'm making this video all the other
all the other games are um uh still
still being played one game ended in a
draw but they are a bit drawish so uh
let's see what happened in this one one
and uh will Magnus be able to grab a
full point with the white pieces in
classical this game so he opens with
Pawn to E4 we have E5 Knight to F3
Knight to C6 and now Bishop to
B5 yeah I can't remember I can't
remember what what's the saying like by
by the skin of his teeth or something
like that yeah it sounds weird now that
I said it but I can't remember so A6
morphe's defense we have Bishop to A4
and now Knight to F6 we have Pawn to D
E3 and now Bishop to C5 so the standard
Anderson variation of the morphy's
defense of the ru Lopez we have C3 by
Magnus Pawn to B5 and Bishop back to B3
we have D6 Bishop to G5 and now even
Pawn to H6 uh Bishop to H4 and Bishop to
A7 so a fairly rare setup but it has
been played before with both white and
black by some very strong players for
example Hans nean had it against saturan
where Hans won Rapport had it against
the ding rort lost that game and Karana
had against John Burke in 2021 us Chess
Championship where Fabby won so it has
been played before in some top games but
they continued with castles and um with
A4 and castles but here we have Knight
beat to D2 and it is now as of move 10
that we have a completely new game so
okay Pawn to G5 we have Bishop to G3 and
now Queen to E7 and whenever I see this
uh G5 H6 and B5 A6 I remember that
Kasparov game he played against uh I
believe it was kpov uh where he said
that it just can't be possible for black
to play like this and okay those were
the pre- engine days where we didn't
understand that pretty much anything can
be played if you prepare it properly uh
but yeah something has to give you it it
it's it looks very unnatural and where
are you putting your king okay if you
Castle King side then those pawns will
become easy targets for the white Army
so Knight to F1 Magnus says all right
you have holes on D5 and F5 and I'm
going to put my knight to E3 and Target
those squares those are a very important
Square so Bishop to E6 and now Knight to
E3 uh Rook to B8 and now we have Castles
by Magnus and here uh H grabs the Knight
on E3 it's it's a magnificent Bishop to
have on this diagonal but the potential
of the Knight to become a great piece uh
outweighs the the potential of this
bishop perhaps so he does go for the
capture we have F captures and now
castles uh we have Knight to D2 and now
Bishop to G4 putting pressure on
magnus's Queen we have Queen to E1 and
now Bishop to H5 transferring the bishop
over to G6 and now Knight to F3 we have
King to G7 and Magnus goes for Knight to
H4 so he shows that uh yeah it's not
going to be possible to play like this
and you cannot capture the Knight if you
capture the Knight then um Knight on F6
will fall uh Magnus will gain back the
material and uh retain a winning
position so instead Bishop back to G6
and now Knight to F5 check forcing he
over to give up the light Square Bishop
as well so Bishop captures and The Rook
captures on F5 so we have this uh
position where okay it uh it emerged out
of a Ru Lopez but it really does look
like something that would emerge out of
an Italian game um you know uh better
than than the R Lopez maybe as now white
has the bishop pair and black has the
two knights uh but okay Knight to D7 you
know that the bishop is attacking F7 The
Rook is attacking F7 the queen will move
and the other Rook will also come to F1
to put more pressure on F7 so you do not
want that pawn on F7 so here Knight to
D7 preparing Pawn to F6 the pawn will be
very strong here as the Knight Will
defended Queen to E2 and now Queen to E8
we have Rook a to F1 doubling up and now
having a lot of pressure on F7 and now
Pawn to F6 so the here the pawn is
defended uh but that means your knight
will have to remain here for a very long
time but Magnus will not just idly wait
he goes for Pawn to H4 Knight to E7 and
now Rook five back to F2 as the Knight
is attacked we have Knight to C5 now uh
and the bishop to C2 first you have to
kick away the Knight and then okay you
can keep the bishop on this diagonal but
as the Knight will not be able to remain
on C5 you will then reclaim this
diagonal for your light Square Bishop so
Knight to G6 attacking the H4 pawn and
Magnus grabs more space with Pawn to
H5 uh so Knight back to E7 and now Pawn
to D4 kicking away the Knight Knight to
D7 and Bishop goes back to B3 so slowly
but surely improving his position as it
is a very very very strong position
uh Rook to d8 Black sort of out of
running out of useful moves you could
play Maybe Rook to C8 preparing Pawn to
C5 but even that isn't all that
impressive he goes for Rook to d8 and
now Magnus plays Pawn to A4 just going
for a captur on B5 then uh the the B5
Pawn would hang uh and now you could
just defend it passively with Rook to B8
sure that's possible then Bishop comes
to E6 and again Magnus will gradually
improve his position uh but after after
the 30th move
was already very long time and he
decided to abandon passive play and he
went for activity with Pawn to F5 this
is a straight up Pawn sacrifice which
he's willing to give in order to keep
his King safe but activate his pieces so
he says all right I'm going to be down a
pawn and maybe I can defend this game
against Magnus we have D captures on E5
sorry not e captures F5 D captures on E5
Knight captures on E5 and now e captures
an F5 so that was the the Free Pawn and
now King to F6 blocking this So
Yesterday Magnus had a losing uh game
but he was able to draw now he has a
well a winning game that he uh we will
see if he can win this so Bishop to E6
uh sorry after King to F6 we have Bishop
to E6 and now Queen to C6 we have a
captur on B5 Queen captur offering a
queen trade but as a general rule if
you're controlling more space you don't
want to trade down you want to keep
material on the board uh Queen to D1 and
now Pawn to A5 we have Pawn to B3 your
pawns are n now nicely defended and Rook
to B8 putting pressure on the pawn but
let's not forget about our good friend
the light Square Bishop also keeping
that B3 Pawn nicely defended we have
Rook to A2 now putting pressure on the
A5 pawn and now Knight s to C6 we have
Pawn to E4 uh and now Queen to C5 with
check it seems that with this Pawn to E4
move Magnus blundered the C3 Pawn but
he's actually sacrificing it uh for uh
counterplay along the C file so Queen to
C5 check he just moves his no he defends
with the bishop Bishop F2 and queen
captures on C3 but now Rook to C2 again
B3 is defended by the bishop so you have
to just move the queen queen to B4 and
now Bishop to D5 defending the E4 Pawn
while putting pressure on the Knight so
how do you defend you can't really play
Rook B6 as the bishop is controlling
that but maybe it's uh even your best
move I allow the engine to Crunch the
numbers here up to like depth 40 and the
engine does give Rook to B6 as the top
move um just saying okay give up that
rook and uh you will give black the this
uh very nice Pawn chain where maybe B5
and A4 can be played in the future to
create a pass Pawn but still it's not
it's not enough for black with precise
play uh but Knight D7 is played and now
just Rook captures on C7 Now The Rook is
extremely strong here uh imagine if you
somehow get this Rook over to F7 without
of course F7 being defended that would
be a very nice checkmate with the pawns
covering everything here uh but okay
there there's still a long way to go for
that Rook F to C8 and now Rook to A7
avoiding the Rook trade and now okay we
reached time control but H is already
very very low on time even upon reaching
time control Magnus has an hour and 10
minutes on the clock H already is down
to 17 minutes here so Rook to C3 and now
Bishop to C4 now Magnus is all right if
you if you want to exchange everything
on C4 then I also win the D6 Pawn with
check uh so Rook to B6 defending that
and now Bishop to D4 just tying up H's
pieces completely Rook captures on C4 uh
yeah okay giving up the exchange but
what else do you play if if Rook to C6
for example Rook comes to A8 then comes
to f8 and there's really not a lot this
black king can do here then F6 F7 and
that's going to be game so after Bishop
to D4 Rook captures and C4 was played B
captures and now Knight to C6 going
after the bishop on D4 uh but just Rook
to H7 and he was in this position un
move 47 that hovin greton resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here also he was down to 1 minute in the
clock when he resigned Rook captures on
H6 is coming and there's no good way to
stop that one fun way a game might
continue is uh well uh you can't move
this Knight it's pinned by the bishop
you can't really capture on C4 because
then The Rook on B6 will be undefended
so what do you play of course you're
going to capture on D4 and after Queen
captures again you cannot take and you
cannot take with a queen as the The Rook
hangs and the Knight is spinned so we
might play Rook to C6 to prepare the
capture but now just Rook captures an H6
with check King G7 Rook G7 check King f8
and now you can even play Pawn to H6 and
if Rook captures on C4 threatening your
queen you can even play Pawn to H7 and
sacrifice your queen and it's a force
Checkmate for white to give you an
example Rook captures h8 brings another
queen into the game King E7 Rook to G7
with check Knight to F7 and now Queen to
C8 with some Queen to E6 uh action to to
be uh followed up with uh D5 and now
Queen to C7 check with whatever you play
is just going to be a very nice
Checkmate so that's why of course H
resigned as there was nothing more to be
done there uh but yeah very nicely done
by Magnus let me just check by the time
I was uh preparing the video uh they
still haven't updated the ratings let me
just see if Magnus won some rating for
this yeah okay with with yesterday 's
draw and today's win he's up 0.3 points
so not getting a lot but yeah I mean
with 300 lower rated opponents 300
points lower rated opponents you can't
really afford even to draw games if you
are to to win rating uh but yeah very
nicely done by Magnus and let me just
check if uh Norway has finished the
match no it's still it's still being
played uh yeah one draw on board three
but uh yeah two of the games still being
played as I'm recording so we'll have to
see what happened in the next video
uh but yeah very nice done by Magnus
comparing this to yesterday's game where
he again faced okay with the black
pieces um somewhat lower rated opponent
uh today's game did seem more of a
target practice for him you know or a
sparring match rather than an actual
battle uh but yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it Magnus uh you know
up to his usual standards uh I would
like to thank Kevin Clark Camilo he schw
schwarzer hop Randall inol Stefan
rosovich and Andreas rosenal for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and everything
else that happens in the Chess World so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your
day